reisefreiheit in europa eingeschränkt
wegen des corona virus machen immer mehr
nachbarländer die grenzen dicht
deutschland kauft ein starker ansturm
auf supermärkte die wirtschaft sieht
keine versorgungsengpässe und biathlon
saison finale der franzose macht gewinnt
das letzte rennen seiner
ausnahmekarriere
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem samstag an meiner seite ist für
den sport norbert lehmann einen guten
hand der familie das corona virus
überschattet alles wir sollen soziale
kontakte nach möglichkeit weitestgehend
einstellen
dazu hat die bundeskanzlerin in ihrem
video-podcast noch mal aufgerufen
der berliner senat hat vor wenigen
minuten beschlossen dass ab sofort alle
veranstaltungen mit mehr als 50
teilnehmern untersagt sind und viele
unserer nachbarn gehen noch weiter sie
lassen niemanden mehr in irland seit der
nacht abgeriegelt tschechien bis auf
wenige ausnahmen darf hier keiner mehr
rein oder raus polen schottet sich um
mitternacht ab für mindestens zehn tage
dürfen keine ausländer ins land und auch
in dänemark sind seit dem mittag die
grenzen dicht heike kruse berichtet
heute 12 uhr mittag am übergang krusau
kurz hinter flensburg die grenze ist
dicht kein ausländer darf mehr nach
dänemark einreisen
auch nicht die nachbarn aus deutschland
zunächst vier wochen lang soll die
grenzschließung dauern
ausnahmen der güterverkehr und
berufspendler
auch für mich persönlich wird
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht bedeuten dass
ich früher aufstehen muss um zur arbeit
zu kommen da ich in dänemark gearbeitet
ich finde es schon schade für den ganzen
grenzverkehr den pendelt den einkauf und
für die ganzen menschen die hier
wirklich hier nun her müssen aber aus
gesundheitlichen gründen akzeptiere ich
das und findet es in ordnung in
tschechien hat die regierung den
notstand ausgerufen
seit mitternacht gilt ein einreiseverbot
für alle personen aus sogenannten corona
hochrisiko ländern auch aus deutschland
weg ist ja weit weg in china und jetzt
auf einmal hier in deutschland jetzt
ergreifen die nach wollen dass solche
maßnahmen nur deutsche die in tschechien
arbeiten dürfen noch ins land alle
personen die einreisen dürfen werden
medizinisch untersucht die grenze soll
zunächst 30 tage geschlossen bleiben
verlängerung möglich die einzelstaaten
in der eu handeln unabhängig voneinander
wir können nicht warten das brüssel uns
einen ratschlag erteilt jedes land geht
mit der situation anders in polen
bereiten polizei und zoll zur zeit noch
die schließung der grenzübergänge vor
ab mitternacht darf auch nach polen kein
ausländer mehr einreisen noch einmal zum
polnischen nachbarn tanken und einkaufen
bevor in ein paar stunden die grenze bei
frankfurt an der oder geschlossen wird
wir fragen nach bei unseren
korrespondenten in brüssel und polen
zunächst von natalie steger die an der
deutsch an der polnisch deutschen grenze
steht warum greift die polnische
regierung zu drastischen maßnahmen
nun die polnische regierung die
präsentiert sich hier als knallharter
krisenmanager premierminister maliki hat
gerade gesagt wir schließen die grenzen
für viren aber nicht für unsere
polnischen mitbürger als ab 24 uhr kommt
dann aus deutschland hier kein ausländer
mehr rein mit ganz wenigen ausnahmen und
die polin die zurückkehren
die müssen erst mal 14 tage lang in
quarantäne
eine ausnahme sind da die fahrer von
güterverkehr also die polnische
regierung hat er wirklich sehr früh und
sehr knallhart durchgegriffen
es gibt aktuell zwei todesopfer zu
beklagen und 93 infizierte die schulen
sind bereits zu kinos theater museen etc
ohnehin die restaurants dürfen seit
heute nur noch take away anbieten also
hinsetzen ist da nicht und in den großen
einkaufs shoppingcentern da ist ja fast
schon gespenstisch weil nur noch
apotheken lebensmittelgeschäften und
drogerien öffnen dürfen also weit
reichende maßnahmen aber ich habe
wirklich den eindruck dass die polen
diese maßnahmen durchaus begrüßen
jedes land macht da sein eigenes ding
wir haben keine zeit um auf ratschläge
aus brüssel zu warten haben wir gerade
aus tschechien gehört 100 drücker welche
rolle spielt überhaupt noch die eben ja
eigentlich spielt die eu ja hier eine
koordinierende rolle aber diese rolle
muss sie erstmal wieder finden am
dienstag hatten sich die staats und
regierungschefs hier noch versprochen
dann wolle er sich in grenzfragen
absprechen das gegenteil ist der fall
sechs von 30 schengen staaten haben bis
jetzt hier nach brüssel gemeldet dass
sie wieder kontrollieren wollen die eu
kommission hat auch grundsätzlich nichts
gegen kontrollen wenn sie sich
medizinisch begründen lassen wenn es
also um fieber messen geht oder um
einreise stopps für menschen aus
risikogebieten
sie hat aber etwas gegen pauschale
einreise stopps oder auch gegen
komplette grenzschließungen man
fürchtete um den binnenmarkt man
fürchtet um die lieferketten in diesem
binnenmarkt die eu wirtschaft ist ja
sehr eng verwoben und die eu
kommissionspräsident in ursula von der
leyen hat deshalb einen vorschlag den
arbeit der wieder zu sinnvollen und
einheitlichen maßnahmen an der grenze
zurückkehren will
deutschland und frankreich hatten das
gefordert wenn das kommt dann kann man
wieder von einer spürbaren koordination
aus brüssel sprechen
ja aber die zeit drängt natürlich
dankeschön nach brüssel und holen gunnar
plümer und natalie steger auch die
türkei versucht mit einreiseverboten die
ausbreitung des corona virus einzudämmen
für reisende aus deutschland und acht
weiteren europäischen ländern ist die
türkische grenze seit heute geschlossen
die ausreise deutscher staatsbürger aus
der türkei soll weiterhin möglich sein
nach italien ist in europa inzwischen
spanien am stärksten betroffen mit mehr
als 5700 infizierten und mehr als 190
toten auch die regierung in madrid plant
offenbar montag landesweite
ausgangssperren alle sollen zu hause
bleiben es sei denn sie müssen dringend
sie müssen arbeiten oder dringendes
einkaufen thomas weiter berichtet je
mehr die zahl der infizierten in die
höhe geht umso mehr sinkt die zahl der
menschen die auf spanischen märkten
einkaufen man versucht direkten kontakt
zu vermeiden so gut es geht
es ist sehr ruhig heute viel ruhiger als
sonst am samstag es sieht so aus als
würden die menschen den empfehlungen
folgen und zu hause bleiben
wegen der gefahr durch das corona virus
geschlossen
madrid kaum wiederzuerkennen läden
restaurants und clubs fürchten um ihre
existenz
wir hoffen dass die regierung die
unternehmen vor dem kollaps bewahrt dass
sie die notwendigen wirtschaftlichen
maßnahmen ergreift die regierung beriet
über maßnahmen die die ausbreitung des
virus begrenzen sollen die angekündigte
erklärung verzögert sich geplant sei so
wie es in einem entwurf eine
ausgangssperre
menschen sollen nur in notfällen oder um
einzukaufen die wohnung verlassen
arbeitgeber werden aufgefordert
heimarbeit einzurichten
eine drastische kurswende zdf-reporterin
brigitte müller lebt in madrid die
menschen sind verunsichert werden von
einer maßnahme der regierung nach der
anderen überrollt vor einer woche noch
wurden hohes veranstaltungen genehmigt
ein paar tage da später dann die schulen
geschlossen und nun heißt es gar dass
man das haus nicht mehr verlassen darf
die maßnahmen sollen ab montag für zwei
wochen gelten eine schließung der
grenzen ist laut dem entwurf des dekrets
nicht vorgesehen
in deutschland haben mittlerweile alle
bundesländer angekündigt ihre schulen zu
schließen oder den unterricht
auszusetzen die zahl der infizierten
liegt nach angaben des robert koch
instituts bei 3062 das ist allerdings
noch der stand von gestern abend die
aktuelleren zahlen der
gesundheitsministerien der länder zeigen
die meisten fälle sind immer noch in
nordrhein westfalen und in bayern und
sie steigen weiter stark an
die verunsicherung ist groß es gebe aber
keinen anlass für hamsterkäufe heißt es
von der bundesregierung david sauer mit
details wenn die nachfrage größer ist
als das angebot sieht das so aus die
deutschen fühlen vorräte auf essen
weniger auswärts und kochen er wieder zu
hause
die folge in manchen supermärkten
ungewohnte leere
extrem hamsterkäufe sind das eigentlich
gar nicht ob er den eindruck dass jeder
hat vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
verkauft hast du sicher
so sind so weit zu fahren einfach zu
hoffen dass alle irgendwie vernünftig
bleiben und alle einfach ganz normal
weiter kaufen ich glaube das ist einfach
die beste lösung genau dazu ruft auch
die bundesernährungsministerin am abend
auf verliere an die verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher maß und mitte zu beachten
und auch solidarisch zu sein mit anderen
verbrauchern
ich kann es verstehen dass große sorge
da ist und wenn man halbleere regale
sieht dann kauft man mehr als man muss
und braucht sonst ein nischenmarkt in
kronau zeiten aber sehr gefragt einkäufe
liefern lassen
nudeln zwieback toilettenpapier online
bestellen und der kurier liefert an die
haustür zum hamstern gibt es keinen
anlass
und daher ist der rat ganz normal weiter
zukaufen
es werden auch weiter die supermärkte
auf haben von daher wird man sich auch
weiter versorgen können bundesweit
schließen in der kommenden woche kitas
und schulen kinderzimmer stadt
klassenraum meist bis zum ende der
osterferien dass jeder mal die kinder
nimmt oder ob ich unbezahlten urlaub
nehmen muss derzeit an die miete fragen
die sich viele eltern stellen schon bis
montag müssen sie darauf eine antwort
finden
in vielen krankenhäusern und
pflegeeinrichtungen sind besuche
verboten oder zumindest eingeschränkt
die schwächsten zu schützen das ist das
gebot dieser außergewöhnlichen tage was
wirklich knapp wird sind blutkonserven
denn offenbar halten sich viele spender
derzeit wegen des corona virus zurück
eine stadt welt hat details die plätze
der blutspendedienste verweist die
regale mit blutkonserven immer leerer
wie hier beim deutschen roten kreuz in
rostock aus sorge vor einer ansteckung
mit dem corona oder grippevirus bleiben
immer mehr blutspender weg in der
uniklinik rostock sind bereits 30
prozent weniger blutkonserven verfügbar
wir haben einerseits jetzt die
ungewöhnliche lage dass wir einerseits
auf die blutspende gucken müssen die ja
erkranken können und ausbleiben
aber bei der krone corona
viruserkrankung haben wir ja die
situation dass auch die mitarbeiter
gesund sein müssen die experten rufen
alle gesunden menschen auf weiter blut
zu spenden
eine gesteigerte ansteckungsgefahr
bestünde dabei nicht
zunächst den wir da kein massiv erhöhtes
risiko für die menschen zumal sie ja
auch nicht gezwungen werden auf extrem
engen raum zusammen zu sitzen
der blutspendedienst des drk will jetzt
seine öffnungszeiten verlängern
blutkonserven werden täglich im ganzen
land gebraucht zum beispiel für
unfallopfer oder krebspatienten da das
blut nicht unendlich lange haltbar ist
sondern dass er trotz übten konzentraten
nur sechs wochen muss dann natürlich
auch immer ein entsprechender also
entsprechender nachschub kommen das drk
setzt auf stammspender wie knut
sommermeyer alle acht wochen kommt er
doch wegen der korona krise hat er
seinen rhythmus verändert
ich bin halt nur eine woche oder zwei
wochen früher gegangen als geplant weil
man nicht weiß ob man in zwei wochen die
chance dazu hat noch reichen die
blutkonserven doch könnte das corona
virus auch hierfür einen engpass sorgen
gesundheitsminister sparen hat per
twitter reisende und ski urlauber aus
italien der schweiz und österreich dazu
aufgerufen
soweit möglich bis zu zwei wochen zu
hause zu bleiben und zwar auch ohne
symptome
gerade aus tirol kommen jetzt viele heim
weil auch dort ab montag alles schließt
britta hilpert
es ist ein bild mit seltenheitswert
kühtai in tirol heute sonne wochenende
und die pisten sind fast leer
für morgen ist das ende der skisaison
angeordnet corona bedingt viele sind
bereits abgefahren anderen nutzen es bis
zum letzten aus natürlich ist es eine
große einschränkung aber wir können
natürlich verstehen durch den chor virus
dass es einschränkungen geben muss also
wir hatten uns auf den pisten auf hier
oben denke ich mal ist die gefahr
deutlich geringer als wenn wir jetzt bei
uns zu hause in düsseldorf waren also
auch eine weitere angst geht um in
hotels und skischulen der vor
wirtschaftlichen folgen 20 prozent der
saison einnahmen fallen weg sagt
skilehrer christoph praxmarer und das
wars für uns jetzt mal geplante weise
bis juni keine arbeit
alle trainer stehen es wird hilfe für
die betriebe geben so erfährt hotelchef
mario gerber während der gäste
verabschiedet 4 milliarden euro gibt die
österreichische regierung für einen
krisenbewältigung fonds
trotzdem es ist ein schwarzer tag für
den tourismus ich bin auch überzeugt
dass diese auswirkungen noch jahrelang
zu spüren sein werden
aber es ist ganz wichtig wir mit seine
verantwortung im tourismus und so werden
die gäste hinauskomplimentiert sie
sollen ab fahren nach hause und dort
dann nach möglichkeit zwei wochen in
quarantäne ging
und es gab auch noch was jenseits des
corona virus endlich wieder genug regen
in diesem viel zu warmen winter
landwirte und forstbetriebe atmen auf
nach zweifel sie verlust vollen dürre
jahren hintereinander
nun sind die grundwasserstände fast
überall in deutschland wieder deutlich
angestiegen nur in teilen
ostdeutschlands noch nicht christopher
heinze den ganzen winter schon ist die
talsperre cranzahl nahe der
tschechischen grenze halb leer
selbst die anhaltenden regenfälle der
vergangenen wochen haben die situation
hier und den weiten teilen sachsens kaum
verändert der grundwasserspiegel seit
vielen monaten extrem niedrig anhand
unseres netzes können wir feststellen
dass die regenfälle der letzten zwei
monate den grundwasserstand um wenige
zentimeter angehoben haben in weiten
teilen deutschlands hat sich dagegen die
situation mittlerweile entspannt das
zeigen die auswertungen der täglichen
niederschlagsmengen des deutschen
wetterdienstes der regen von februar bis
mitte märz hat der so genannten
bodenfeuchte und damit auch dem
grundwasser gut getan
nur in sachsen thüringen sachsen anhalt
und brandenburg liegen noch trockene
gebiete betroffen vor allem tiefere
schichten die obersten bodenschichten
jetzt in dem fall sind sie so bis 40 50
zentimeter ausgefüllt man kann aber auch
so bis zwei meter tief in den boden
gucken modellieren und da haben wir dann
inzwischen in vielen regionen
deutschlands doch den boden so weit
aufgefüllt dass auch in zwei meter tiefe
keinen bodenfeuchte defizit mehr
herrscht ausgiebiger regen
ostdeutschland könnte ihn in vielen
gebieten weiterhin gebrauchen damit die
talsperren irgendwann wieder auf normale
pegel kommen jetzt zu der norbert etwas
sport gibt es dann auch noch trotz ja
zum beispiel das vorzeitige finale der
biathlon saison im finnischen
kontiolahti und da holt frankreichs
superstar marta vor seinem 79
weltcupsieg zuvor hatte er verkündet das
ist das letzte rennen meiner karriere
noch einmal lassen seine
mannschaftskameraden ihn hochleben und
abstürzen ein ungewohntes gefühl für den
besten biathleten der vergangenen dekade
trotz insgesamt drei schießfehlern
verabschiedet sich der siebenmalige
gesamtweltcupsieger standesgemäß ein
sieg vor den wegen kroner leeren
tribünen in kontiolahti genau hier und
auf den tag vor zehn jahren hat man
erfolg hat sein erstes weltcup rennen
gewonnen
dem norweger johannes teenies bereich
platz vier um den franzosen zum
abschluss den gesamtweltcup mit gerade
mal zwei punkten vorsprung
wegzuschnappen
eine durchwachsene saison der deutschen
männer endet genauso mit platz fünf ist
arnd peiffer der einzige unter den
besten zehn
und die deutschen biathlon-frauen im
gegensatz zum doppler vorgestern heute
wenig erfolgreich die beste deutsche in
der verfolgung franziska preuß als
neunter ja und mehr biathlon im
aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr das top
thema aber natürlich dass corona virus
und die folgen für den weltsport mit
vielen interessanten gesprächskosten
maximilian schacht mann ist der sieger
des vorzeitig beendeten radrennen
klassikers paris nizza der größte erfolg
seiner karriere einen tag früher als
geplant und fernab größerer
menschenmengen in den französischen
seealpen muss schacht man am
schlussanstieg auf die attacke seines
schärfsten verfolgers reagieren der
belgier tiefster not liegt in der
gesamtwertung nur 36 sekunden hinter dem
deutschen
der trägt seit beginn des einwöchigen
traditionsrennens das gelbe trikot
hinter dem tagessieger kind anna aus
kolumbien wird b-note zweiter aber es
reicht nicht für ihn
schach man verliert nur 18 sekunden
seines vorsprungs erst völlig erschöpft
es war wie ein gang durch die hölle für
mich aber jetzt fühle ich mich wie im
himmel
der größte erfolg des 26 jahre alten
berliners und seines deutschen teams
immer auf einige zeit wahrscheinlich
letzten großen radrennen das war mir
wenigstens einer fühlt sich wie im
himmel die italiener trotzen der
quarantäne auf ihre ganz eigene art wäre
es gestern schon gezeigt uns heute noch
einmal weil es so schön ist und weil
immer mehr italiener mitmachen
[Musik]
im ganzen land folgen die menschen den
online aufrufen ein musikinstrument zu
nehmen und einfach gegen die einsamkeit
an zu singen damit das land trotz corona
für ein paar minuten ein einziges großes
konzert ist
[Musik]
und noch was erfreuliches der frühling
kommt morgen mit sonne und 9 bis 17 grad
die details hat gleich katja manöver
claus kleber bringt sie im heute journal
um viertel vor elf auf den neuesten
stand morgen begrüßt sie hier
petra gerster danke für ihr interesse
alles gute ihnen und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren wenn der frühling
zu uns kommt dann eigentlich immer aus
südwesten dort liegen morgen schon die
höchsttemperaturen hier über der
iberischen halbinsel bei 15 bis 25 grad
während es in osteuropa kalt bleibt mit
fünf grad
da ist es zum teil manchmal nachts bei
uns wärmer zum beispiel in emmerich
heute nacht mit sieben grad kalt wird es
dagegen zwischen görlitz und cottbus mit
minus vier grad unter klarem
sternenhimmel im westen sind die wolken
dagegen dicht und diese dichteren wolken
die ziehen morgen im laufe des tages
weiter nach osten erreichen wismar das
wendland und das wiehengebirge und in
nordfriesland kann es doch mal leicht
tröpfeln sonst aber scheint häufig die
sonne bei südwind und vor allen dingen
südlich von köln frankfurt erfurt und
dresden scheint die sonne zum teil
strahlend die temperaturen sind noch
recht unterschiedlich im osten bereits
frisch bei zehn oder elf grad am rhein
und im münsterland dagegen steigen die
werte doch schon auf 14 bis 17 grad und
im laufe der nächsten tage wird es von
tag zu tag wärmer am mittwoch erwarten
uns dann höchsttemperaturen meist
zwischen 16 und 21 grad und nur in einem
etwa 50 kilometer breiten küstenstreifen
bleibt es bei 11 bis 13 grad kühler
und dazu scheint ganz häufig die sonne
besonders am mittwoch in süddeutschland
schönes wochenende